non à 11h sur public sénat
ravi de vous retrouver dans parlement
hebdo 45 minutes d'actualité politique
et parlementaire bonjour michaëlle jean
chrétien est la une cette semaine le
coup d'envoi du marathon budgétaire à
l'assemblée les députés ont entamé
l'examen des recettes le projet de loi
prévoit 3 milliards de hausse d'impôts
et 15 milliards d'économies l'effort
repose essentiellement sur les ménages
ne prendront la direction de marseille
pour la primaire socialiste en vue des
élections municipales
ambiance pour le moins électrique entre
sam et gallier patrick mennucci pour le
débat d'entre deux tours accusations en
tous genres la réconciliation prendra
certainement un petit peu de temps et
puis il ya un an des marettes un long
bras de fer à notre dame des landes d'un
côté des crs mobilisés sur la zone de
construction du nouvel aéroport de
l'autre des opposants au projet qui
tienne bon un documentaire diffusé sur
notre antenne revient sur cette lutte
c'est le plus de parlement hebdo et pour
commenter toute cette actualité bonjour
barbara pompili nom jean député
écologiste de la somme coprésidente du
groupe écologiste à l'assemblée
nationale membre de la commission des
affaires culturelles et de l'éducation
alors je vous propose de regarder avec
nous cette petite image qu'on va vous
proposer c'était votre première
intervention dans l'hémicycle 24 juillet
2012 c'était de questions d'actualité
plutôt sage peut-être un petit peu
impressionné alors un nom et demi plus
tard on va voir ce que disent vos
confrères de vous si vous voulez bien
écouter investi engagé et en même temps
respectueuse percutante dans
dans ses interventions
parfois un peu éloigné des réalités
du terrain très certainement efficacité
calmer sens de la répartie basse et
vindicative par moments ayant de
l'obstination et puis parfois excessives
voilà sincère quelqu'un qui a des
convictions et combative je crois que
c'est une bonne présidente au co
présidente de groupes écologistes le
décret n'est pas parce que franchement
je n'ai pas beaucoup d'atomes crochus
avec la prétention
réaction j'entends excessive
travailleuses bonne élève qu'est ce que
vous préférez parmi tous ces
qualificatifs aux fouilles un peu de
vrai dans tout ça alors je suis
quelqu'un qui a des convictions et c'est
vrai que parfois on se laisse emporter
par l'enthousiasmé parfois aussi en se
disant mince que les choses n'avancent
pas assez vite après je pense que je
suis aussi quelqu'un de compromis et
c'est important en politique de savoir
passer des compromis parce que le
jusqu'au boutisme ça ne mène nulle part
alors barbara peuple et c'est parti pour
une semaine très politique qui commence
sur fond d'élection
lundi marquée par la victoire du fn à
brignoles son candidat laurent lopez a
battu l'ump catherine d'heure avec mille
voix d'avancé appels au front
républicain n'a visiblement pas
fonctionné pour cette cantonale
partielle pierre lascars et charleville
à neuf étaient sur place la candidate
ump s'est voulue jusqu'au bout confiante
et sûr de l'efficacité du front
républicain j'attends la proclamation un
combat n'est jamais perdu jusqu'à la
dernière seconde à
le faire
l'ofev un peu avant 20 heures les
résultats tombent avec plus de 53% cette
victoire sans appel du candidat fn
laurent lopez
ça montre les gens se sont réveillés 50
on écoute aussi l'ump sa mort que le
système est tombé ce soir mais pour
laurent lopez pas question de voir dans
le score de dimanche un aboutissement
mais plutôt une promesse d'autres
victoires lors de futurs scrutins est ce
qu'il y aura un avant après écoute et
j'espère sincèrement que brignoles nord
europe dès le début de la reconquête
notre pays voilà et c'est à manifester
les sports pour tous ceux qui souffrent
de ce mal français quelques ténors
frontiste avait fait le déplacement
l'occasion d'annoncer la mort du
républicain
même si le score est impressionnant il
reste toutefois à relativiser le fn a
certes gagné hier soir son deuxième
conseiller général mais le maillage du
territoire par un tissu de l'ue locaux
bleu marine reste encore loin
barbara bon pili ce résultat de
brignoles pour vous c'est avant tout une
victoire du fn ou une défaite du front
républicain
je crois que c'est c'est une défaite des
partis républicains en général qui se
retrouve à devoir gérer une situation
dans laquelle on voit bien qu'il ya un
lien qui s'est coupé avec les gens et
moi ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup c'est
quand je vois les réactions
depuis cette élection que ce soit à
gauche comme à droite où on a tendance à
se renvoyer dos à dos à ce sens voyez
les invectives les uns les autres je ne
vois pas en quoi ces réactions
politiciennes vont améliorer la
situation donc moi witi côtier vous avez
bien entendu que vous avez bien entendu
aussi ce qu'a dit le parti socialiste si
nous parti socialiste nous ne sommes pas
au deuxième tour c'est à cause de nos
analystes à cause du fait que vous les
verts qui restent parti en solitaire
mais on
les écologistes sont évidemment
responsable de tout ce qui se passe de
pas bien dans ce pays non responsable
alors je pense que on a une
responsabilité collective et qu' il va
falloir qu'on se pose les bonnes
questions l'avancé des extrêmes a
toujours existé dans les périodes de
crise on est en période de crise donc il
ya déjà cet élément là à prendre en
compte face à cette période de crise
qu'est ce que nous proposons comme
réponse et c'est cela ou le problème là
les réponses proposées par le
gouvernement ça ne va pas assez vite il
ya aussi une attente absolue et là on
sent que le gouvernement ne répond pas
suffisamment vite aux attentes des gens
donc ça c'est le premier problème et
l'opposition en face est tellement dans
ces batailles internes ces batailles de
leadership au plus tôt fin mai que nés
les gens se disent mais l'opposition
n'apporte rien non plus comme
proposition pour régler nos problèmes
qui sont centrés sur leurs problèmes et
ils ne regardent pas nos problèmes
résultat évidemment ça attise les
mécontentements et les voies vont vers
le front national a écouté la détention
jld eu la mention je vous propose
d'écouter l'analyse du premier ministre
jean marc ayrault après ce résultat la
responsabilité des dirigeants de l'ump
qui n'ont même pas levé le petit doigt
pour défendre leur candidate est
extrêmement importante il faut pas qu'il
s'étonne ainsi qu'une partie de leurs
électeurs les fuit pour aller
directement vers ce parti c'est ce que
vous disiez l'ump et le ps qui se
renvoient dos à dos voilà ça ne peut pas
continuer comme ça jusqu'aux élections
municipales
vraiment moi je fais un appel à tous les
politiques pour que le niveau remonte
pour que les gens que moi je vois dans
ma permanence quelqu'un d ajuster les
déconnecter du terrain enfin il faudrait
qu'on nous suivent un peu sur le terrain
pour comprendre qu'au contraire on voit
ce qui se passe et ce qu'on voit c'est
que les gens disent vous ne vous
intéressez pas à nous on se sent
abandonnés vous sentez cette
démobilisation de la gauche notamment
sur le terrain
cc c'est plutôt un sentiment la gauche
donne un sentiment d'impuissance et
c'est vrai que les atermoiements des
politiques qui sont menées c'est à dire
on avance on recule on hésite c'est très
mauvais parce que du coup les gens se
disent à tort d'ailleurs mais se disent
il n'y a pas de cap et ça c'est pas
rassurant et quand on est dans une
période de crise quand on voit les
usines qui ferment terrain on a besoin
d'avoir des gens qui donne un cap le
front national donne un très mauvais cap
mais il en donne un vain mot barbare
billy parce que ce que j'entends c'est
une vraie critique du gouvernement une
vraie critique aussi de la ligne suivie
par le prieur de la république n'ont
cessé de la ligne une crétine de la
communication autour de la ligne et
c'est une critique aussi on en parlera
peut-être mais effectivement de certains
atermoiements notamment sur le budget il
dira l'ombre d'ailleurs et voilà
notamment sur le budget qui font que
vraiment on a l'impression qu'il n'y a
pas de ligne alors que encore une fois
ce ce n'est pas le cas mais certaines
certains éléments de communication font
que les gens croient que ben on navigue
à vue alors on va en parler mais en
attendant une autre ville est sous les
feux de l'actualité marseille où a lieu
la primaire socialiste la sénatrice
samia ghali a créé la surprise en se
qualifiant pour le second tour tout
comme patrick mennucci la ministre marie
arlette carlotti a été éliminé un
scrutin sur fond de soupçons et
d'accusations et un débat pour le moins
tendu entre deux tours entre patrick
mennucci s'amaigrit je vous propose
évidemment de regarder cet extrait qu'on
va commenter ensemble
patrick lynch qui a le soutien des élus
moi je les soutiens des marseillais
finalement ceux qui l'ont expliqué
pendant des mois et des mois qu'ils
étaient nés lentilles système anti
magouilles anti discussion entre amis
et c'est ce qu'ils entendent elle est
pratiquée aujourd'hui moi je n'ai rien
demandé à personne je n'ai fait aucun
arrangement et personne je n'ai
absolument rien promis à personne les
jeunes font le single et d'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs il vaut bien marché
je m'interromps la première dit n'a pas
changé il a reconnu il a reconnu aux
jeunes qu'il a eu et tous les temps mais
les toits même patrick odier a ils ont
promis un poste de sénateur et cognac
ont émis se situe à 10 à patrick chiche
programme mondial
patrick je regrette vraiment que tu as
baisse l'autre débat envoyé pour le
climat va payer on va s'intéresser aux
primaires ps aux primaires en général
c'est le plus de l'hebdo
commentés notamment ses rôles des
primaires dans la vie politique denis
jeambar notre éditorialiste nous a
rejoint bonjour de bonjour alors
justement ces primaires vous l'avez vu
cet extrait c'est assez significatif
n'est jamais un long fleuve tranquille
oui mais celle du parti socialiste
pendant l'élection présidentielle
n'avait pas été non plus un long fleuve
tranquille il faut s'en souvenir il y
avait eu des phrases assez rude qui
avaient été prononcées notamment contre
françois hollande je vous rappelle quand
par martine aubry
quand il ya du flou il ya un loup
c'était pas une phrase donc plus
d'écran bon que ça ces primaires moi je
crois je crois que les primaires c'est
un progrès de la démocratie et c'est un
moyen aussi d'établir une fluidité entre
les parties les militants mais aussi les
sympathisants et les français en général
donc je trouve que globalement c'est un
progrès démocratique et que ça sera
irréversible dans notre vie politique et
que tu vois là je c'est une très grande
nouveauté dont on mesure peut-être pas
toutes les conséquences ça va pas sans
débat chaotique mais la politique c'est
aussi le débat le débat chaotique chez
vous aussi vous avez connu ça à nicolas
hulot et eva joly oui oui non je suis
d'accord avec vous globalement je pense
que les primaires sont plutôt une
avancée parce que ça permet aussi à des
gens qui ne sont pas investis dans les
partis politiques de venir donner un
avis et faire avancer le débat en plus
ça permet aussi de parler un peu de fond
puisque on est dans des frites dans des
primaires sur des gens qui sont
normalement du même bord politique donc
c'est intéressant et moi j'étais même
assez favorable dans pour les
municipales dans certaines villes où une
figure ne s'imposait pas
particulièrement de faire des primaires
pour à toute la gaule par exemple des
primaires ouvertes sur toute la gauche
ça peut ça peut s'entendre dans
certaines villes ça pouvait s'entendre
annonça pouvait si ça pouvait même
s'entendre à amiens où je suis denis
jeambar on al'impression on a vu qu'à
mais un débat assez cacophonique on a
l'impression qu'il faut vraiment être à
marseille marseillais pour pour
comprendre quelque chose à ce bon il
faut quand même rappeler rappeler le nom
de participants à la primaire au premier
tour il ya quand même eu vingt mille
personnes c'est qu'au moment de la
présidentielle il ya eu 27 mille
personnes à marseille donc sur une
élection comme ça ça mobilise quand même
beaucoup de monde et même si on les
amène en bus et en voiture c'est quand
même beaucoup de monde qui se déplace et
qui s'intéresse donc il ya un vrai
intérêt ensuite ma la politique c'est ça
aussi et on voit bien qu'il ya deux
stratégies différentes sur marseille
dany considérable finalement il se
réconcilieront après l'élection vous
savez en a tellement vu c'est ça aussi
le débat politique on s'affronte on se
confronte et après on se retrouve à
l'aise parfois des traces mais pas tant
que ça justement ça laisse des traces
nicolas hulot et eva joly on en parlait
tout à l'heure la syrie conciliables
c'est pas c'est pas irréconciliable
nicolas hulot a mal vécu ce qui est
arrivé est aussi le fait que nous
justement on avait une primaire ouverte
mais où finalement peut-être qu'on a pas
réussi à attirer suffisamment de monde
sur ces primaires parce que on n'est pas
un peu un aussi gros party que ça on n'a
peut-être pas aussi en termes de délais
réussi à faire comme il fallait c'est un
début les primaires c'est pas évident
mais en ce qui concerne marseille je
pense qu'il ya aussi un arrière
il ya quand même lourd passé politique à
marseille a quand même le système
guérini qui perdure qui a qui n'a jamais
été vraiment solide et c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire puisque monsieur
guérini
détention ça crée des tensions et on
voit bien que là ce qui est en train de
ressortir c'est toutes ces tensions là
quelque part est ce que c'est pas plutôt
une bonne chose que finalement on purge
un peu tout ça je pensais plutôt une
bonne chose est que et que les arbitres
soient les marseillais plutôt que de
l'inter mais je pense que c'est une très
bonne chose cela dit je rappelle que sur
marseille mais aussi d'autres
possibilités
voilà on peut aussi faire une
respiration politique en votant pour
karim zéribi qui est issue qui lui aussi
issu des quartiers marseillais et qui a
beaucoup de choses à proposer moi je
trouve que cela il ya aussi
d'intéressants alors s'il ya une
confrontation mais il ya aussi deux fois
deux lignes politiques qui s'affrontent
et on voit bien d'ailleurs que même galy
et là elle joue les marseillais contre
paris mais ça c'est une tradition il ya
une identité il ya un ads
composer paris ah ça je crois qu'elle
l'a compris c'est ce qui peut réserver
une surprise car d'ailleurs nourri la
surprise du premier tour et qui peut se
retrouver
au second tour merci beaucoup merci
donné alors on passe à mardi avec le
coup d'envoi d'un débat marathon
c'est un moment fort de la vie
parlementaire les députés ont entamé
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
pour 2014 ils ont commencé par les
recettes c'est-à-dire les impôts les
grandes lignes de ce texte avec elisa
bertolo mais pas de pause fiscale en
2014 le projet de loi de finances
comporte bien 3 milliards d'euros de
prélèvements supplémentaires
c'est essentiellement sur les ménages
que va porter cet effort via une baisse
du quotient familial ou le maintien du
taux réduit de tva à 5,5 pour cent
le gouvernement parle de quasi
stabilisation des impôts mais un
sentiment de ras-le-bol fiscale persiste
pour adoucir ses hausses de prélèvements
en commission des finances la semaine
dernière les députés ont voté quelques
aménagements par exemple l' avantage
fiscal pour les parents d'enfants
scolarisés dans le secondaire et le
supérieur est maintenu les entreprises
seront mieux lotis la montée en
puissance du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité et emploi restituera 10
milliards d'euros aux entreprises via
une baisse du coût du travail
la taxe sur l'excédent brut
d'exploitation ne verra pas le jour elle
sera remplacée par une surtaxe de
l'impôt sur les sociétés la taxe à 75%
fait son grand retour dans ce projet de
loi de finances elle sera acquittée par
les entreprises et non par les ménages
pour les salaires supérieurs à 1 million
d'euros mais l'essentiel du budget porte
sur des économies le gouvernement doit
réduire les dépenses de 15 milliards
d'euros pour ramener le déficit à 3 6%
du pib l'objectif fixé par bruxelles
alors barbara pompe il est votre groupe
a obtenu les les avancées que vous
souhaitiez que vous demandiez notamment
sur la fiscalité écologique est ce que
tu es lequel vous allez donc le voter ce
budget 2014 on va pas on va pas jouer à
se faire peur on a eu on s'est fait peur
au début septembre parce que le budget
qui était annoncé une tenu compte en
rien de ce que nous avions déjà négocié
avec le parti socialiste donc là on a
été obligé de taper du poing sur la
table et vous ses gardes depuis depuis
on a obtenu un certain nombre de progrès
qui sont significatifs notamment la tva
baissé pour la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments qui va vraiment relancer un
secteur qui en a besoin et en plus dans
le sens du développement durable donc
c'est vraiment une surprise une chose
non c'est pas suffisant on a réussi
aussi à obtenir notamment des baisses
de commandes il ya un début de fiscalité
qui s'appuie plus sur la pollution et
moins sur les salaires ce qu'on demande
depuis très longtemps de réorienter la
fiscalité et qu'elle pèse moins sur les
salaires et puis on a réussi aussi à
obtenir des exonérations des deux des
suppressions d'exonérations par exemple
sur les engrais les engrais qui avaient
un avantage alors qu'ils étaient cette
question très précise pour avoir
justement pour bénéficier de cette tva
sur la rénovation thermique il a fallu
ne pas augmenter la tva sur les produits
de première nécessité à devait passer à
5 % le reste à 5 5 c'est quand même il
ya une contradiction
pour ceux qui ont donc besoin pour le
coq tous n'étaient pas d'accord on a
voté contre 1 d'ailleurs le fait de
rester à 5,5 ne pense qu'il fallait à
partir du moment où s'était contenté
lui a d'autre moyen de financer de
financer ça par exemple il faudrait
s'occuper du crédit impôt recherche qui
se pose de vrais problèmes
d'optimisation fiscale car c'est devenu
une aubaine pour certaines entreprises
alors que c'est pas ça l'objectif
l'objectif c'est de développer
évidemment la recherche et le
développement qui sont très importants
pour avancer vers l'investissement et
puis vers vers le l'orientation vers
d'autres modes de production mais ça on
peut le faire en ayant un crédit impôt
recherche un peu plus calibré parce que
pour l'instant amiante il est calibré on
perd beaucoup d'argent il ya beaucoup
d'effets d'aubaine et s'il fallait pas y
toucher moi j'aurais préféré qu'on n'y
touche pas mais a maintenant 5 5,5
attention on n'est pas non plus sur une
énorme différence c'est moi je trouve
que
c'est typiquement ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure il y a un problème à
bercy et là moi je le dis au
gouvernement il y a un problème à bercy
qui balance comme ça des idées problème
exactement moi vraiment je pense que ce
sont les services de bercy les services
de bercy mais non parce que les
ministres on leur propose plein de
choses il ministe pas être spécialiste
de tout maintenant je pense que les
ministres doivent avoir une ligne et que
bercy doit servir cette ligne le fait
qu'on balance comme ça des annonces
qu'on retire après c'est pas il y en a
eu plein je pense le bo par exemple je
pense aussi à ça ça donne cette
impression dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure d'un espèce de naviguer à vue et
qui est très préjudiciable sur tout le
monde donc quand on annonce quelque
chose on s'y tient et là le problème
c'est que on fait un pas en avant un pas
en arrière un patient côté ce n'est plus
possible et sur cette affaire de budget
ça pose des problèmes
avec le budget mais a peut-être un petit
peu autres qu'avec l'économie vous avez
une bière c'est préjudiciable ou pas
cette niche et a eu un accord entre edf
et areva pour la vente de 2 p r mot
anglais donc le nucléaire encore du
nucléaire toujours du nucléaire vous
étiez contre il ya un coup de canif dans
le contrat
non la nounou ce qu'on nous ce qu'on
veut c'est baisser la part du nucléaire
dans
l'électricité consommée en france donc
passé de 75 à 50% est ce qu'on demande
au gouvernement c'est que dans la loi de
sur la transition énergétique qui va
arriver au printemps prochain que la
trajectoire pour arriver à cet objectif
soit expliqué soit épi soit soit montrée
dans le temps qu'on ait un calendrier et
c est une méthode parce que pour
l'instant c'est un peu flou et c'est
vrai que mon avance on avance et il faut
qu' il faut que ce soit plus précis que
ça alors on va parler également de la
réforme des retraites que les députés
ont adopté voté en première lecture et
de justesse 270 pour
249 contre et 40 9 abstentions il faudra
travailler plus longtemps les salariés
devront payer plus au titre des
cotisations vieillesse et les retraités
paieront davantage aux six premières
réformes d'un gouvernement de gauche
barbara compilé pourtant les verts se
sont abstenus pourquoi oui on sait ça a
été douloureux pour nous parce que c'est
vrai que c'est on considère que c'est
une occasion manquée cette réforme des
retraites il fallait remettre à plat le
système qui est un vieux système qui est
basé sur une économie et sur une période
historique n'a plus du tout rien à voir
avec ce que c'est ce qui existe
maintenant
donc on c'est une occasion manquée
maintenant après il faut regarder le
texte tel qu'il est on nous a manqué
pour que vous votiez 7
il y avait quelque chose en trop c'est à
dire qu' il y avait l'allongement de la
durée des cotisations
cet allongement de la durée des
cotisations qui est complètement
incompréhensible dans la mesure où on
sait que maintenant les gens à partir de
55 ans a énormément qui ne travaillent
plus qu'ils sont au chaud le choix vous
cotisez on est sur un système absurde en
plus qui va qui va certainement être
revu puisque la mise en oeuvre est
prévue pendant très longtemps je pense
que faire ça ça montrait qu'on n'avait
pas voulu toucher au système et qui ont
trouvé une solution qui était très
mauvaise donc nous on ne pouvait pas
voter rien qu'à cause de ça il ya
d'autres éléments mais l'allongement de
la durée de cotisation n'était pas
possible la majorité socialiste quand
vous vous abstenez sur les retraites
ça les embête ça les embête cela dit on
n'a pas voté contre non plus même si on
aurait pu se poser la tension s'est pas
montré très content parce que il ya
quand même quelques avancées moi
j'essaye j'essaye de ne pas tomber dans
la caricature donc j'essaye de dire les
choses sur la pénibilité il ya un vrai
changement d'état d'esprit ça va toucher
beaucoup de monde dix mots amers en
europe que c'est une première c'est une
première en europe et il faut le saluer
c'est pour ça que nous on ne voulait pas
voté contre parce qu'on ne voulait pas
on voulait montrer qu'on salué cet
effort là mais le problème du
financement des retraites n'est pas
résolu et les solutions qui ont été
trouvées ne sont pas bonnes puisqu'on
parle bien venir la france vous le savez
peut-être veut accueillir l'exposition
universelle de 2025 à présentera sa
candidature
deux parlementaires soutiennent ce
dossier les explications de julie l'un
des trottoirs roulants une première
ligne de métro un petit et un grand
palais 50 millions de visiteurs nous
sommes en 1900 paris accueille
l'exposition universelle un événement
qui n'a pas été réédité depuis et si la
france n'est posé sa candidature pour
2025 une idée lancée il ya deux ans par
le député maire de neuilly-sur-seine
jean-christophe fromantin la france a
besoin peut être aujourd'hui plus que
jamais de retrouver un élan de se
remobiliser de de se recréer un
rassemblement l'idée c'est de deux
d'avoir un territoire de projets qu'ils
soient nouveaux mails et paris a été le
territoire de projets des expos du 19e
siècle le grand paris doit être le
territoire de projets des expos du 21e
siècle et le grand paris articulé avec
ces métropoles avec les grandes
métropoles françaises le concept ray
employés de façon éphémère les
infrastructures du futur grand paris et
les monuments existants des grandes
villes françaises la tour eiffel relooké
par les chinois versailles réinventé par
le brésil chaque exposant se verrait
attribuer un lieu pour une performance
qui devrait faire appel aux nouvelles
technologies
là où quelques-uns qui nous écouterait
se dire mais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette lubie de finalement deux élus
locaux lé maire de neuilly et
d'alfortville qui auraient envie
d'initier ce projet ce qu'il n'y a pas
mieux à faire moment on parle de crise
de compétitivité de chômage est bien au
contraire ce projet ne peut être que
fédérateur un fédérateur économique un
booster d'aménagement du territoire
l'association expo france 2025 créé pour
soutenir cette candidature s'est déjà
attiré le soutien de grands acteurs
économiques politiques et universitaires
objectif être prêt pour le dépôt des
candidatures en 2016 babu qui attendait
beaucoup de choses sur le terrain vous
entendez c'est la crise on peut rien
faire voilà un projet qui bouge qui
parle d'avenir aulas je pense que les
gens damien se contrefoutent de ce
projet pour l eau claire mais après je
découvre parce que j'étais pas au
courant de cette de cette candidature là
si ça peut permettre de montrer vers où
on veut aller si ça peut permettre de
donner des perspectives de voir dans
quel monde on veut avoir demain pourquoi
pas le première c'est un petit peu des
séminaires gouvernementaux disent qu'est
ce qu'on fera en 2020 oui mais après le
problème c'est que ce genre de chose en
général c'est plutôt pour montrer comme
on est beaux par rapport aux autres
c'est c'est souvent la promotion du
gigantisme c'est souvent la promotion
des grands champions de montrer aux qui
est enfin voilà qui est fédérateur aussi
quand même ça dépend comment c'est fait
il me semble que là l'exposition
universelle on avait aussi exposé des
indigènes de manière pas très
respectueuse des droits de l'homme à
l'époque donc je pense que tout ça il
faut faire attention si c'est quelque
chose qui est tourné vers le monde qui
est tourné vers la coopération qui est
tourné vers l'entrée des verts des
valeurs humanistes ça peut pourquoi pas
être intéressant après dépenser des
sommes folles pour une opération malgré
tout de communication attention dans la
période il faut faire
changement imposé alors on va revenir au
coeur de l'actualité avec mercredi une
affaire à la une qui suscite
l'indignation à gauche
leonarda 15 ans kosovars interpellées
pendant une sortie scolaire et expulsé
vers son pays cela s'est passé le 9
octobre dernier dans le doubs depuis l'
affaire provoque une tempête au sein de
la gauche le ministre de l'intérieur est
mis en cause radicale tout a commencé à
la sortie du conseil des ministres
en l'absence de manuel valls en
déplacement vincent peillon a dû
répondre aux questions sur les
conditions d'expulsion de léonard da une
kosovare de 15 ans reconduite à la
frontière lors d'une sortie scolaire une
sortie scolaire
c'est de la scolarité est notre règle
c'est qu'on intervienne pas lorsqu'il ya
scolarité je demande donc on sanctuarise
l'école qu'on garde nos principes de
droit et nos principes d'humanité à
l'avenir parti socialiste c'est l'
indignation après les propos de manuel
valls sur l'impossible l'intégration des
roms l'expulsion de léonard da scolarisé
depuis cinq ans en france provoquent un
tollé qu'on soit dans la majorité ou
dans l'opposition il ya des lignes
rouges a pas dépassé
on a dépassé la ligne rouge c'est pas
une expulsion c'est une rafle aller
chercher un enfant dans son école et sa
la gauche ne peut pas signer ce type
d'accord donc c'est inacceptable
léonarde a été scolarisé la famille de
léonard da est présente en france depuis
2009 donc la famille de léonard da était
à 8 semaines de satisfaire aux critères
de la circulaire de régularisation de
novembre dernier il ya quelques années
quand ça arrive et quand nous étions
dans l'opposition on était ému et
souvent indignée et y'a pas de raison
que on n'est pas les mêmes sentiments
quand ça arrive aujourd'hui le clivage
est nette du côté l'ump on soutient
manuel valls ministre favoris de la
droite peut pas critiquer nos intérieurs
sur une expulsion l'appliquent les lois
de la république
et si on commence à jouer à chaque franc
d emmener elle était là depuis un
certain temps ce que je peux comprendre
à ce moment là il ya une règle dans
l'après-midi la polémique continue
d'enfler et s'invite aux questions au
gouvernement est ce que pour colmater
l'explosion de votre majorité vous allez
sacrifier un préfet de la république qui
n'a fait qu'une chose son travail en
fonction des résultats de cette enquête
monsieur le président david jacobs je
prendrai toutes les responsabilités qui
sen qui s'imposeront le moment venu et
s'il y avait eu faute
l'arrêté de reconduite à la frontière
sera annulée cette famille reviendra
pour que sa situation soit examinée
réexaminer en fonction de notre droit de
nos principes et de nos valeurs
l'enquêté administrative ouverte par le
ministère de l'intérieur rendra ses
conclusions dans 48 heures alors la
sphère est loin d'être terminée
puisqu'on a appris que le père avait
menti sur les origines kosovar de sa
famille bref rien n'est encore clair
dans cette affaire il ya une enquête en
cours quelle est votre position
certains demandent des sanctions et
notamment jusqu'à la démission de manuel
valls c'est ce que vous demandez vous si
non alors
moi je vois que on est en train de faire
encore de la politique politicienne sur
des sujets qui sont des sujets graves
donc moi j'essaye de regarder plutôt le
fond de la sphère le fond c'est que on a
des règles sur la politique
d'immigration qui à mon avis sont plus
très adapté et de toute façon quelles
que soient les résultats de l' enquête
administrative
qui hume ou non une faute on voit que la
manière dont ça s'est passé ça nous
interpelle tous ça nous interpelle tous
parce qu on est dans de l'humain on est
dans de l'alu de choc c'est plus les
conditions de l'interpellation de
l'homme
ce qui me choque c'est que c'est que
manifestement on n'est plus dans un
traitement humain des choses et ne
jamais oublier et ça c'est la sphère
leonarda qu'il a peut être montré mais
on en a tous dans nos circonscriptions
moi j'ai une lycéenne qui s'appelle nan
et qui est dans la situation dans la
même situation et d'ailleurs qui reçoit
un soutien de tous les lycéens qui sont
avec elle donc on est face à des
affaires humaines et donc qu'il ne faut
jamais les traiter comme des affaires de
chiffres il faut les traiter comme des
affaires humaines après qu'il faille des
règles je l'entends est ce qu'elles sont
encore adapté c'est avoir plus d'heures
peut-être peut-être ne fait que le fait
que pour demander une régularisation des
personnes soient obligés de payer 50
euros je peux vous dire que rien que ça
ça pose un problème parce que des gens
du cou qui n'ont pas fn général cumul ça
c'est à dire que ce sont des gens qui
sont d'une extrême pauvreté ne peuvent
pas sortir comme ça 50 euros donc on
voit bien que on a des règles à revoir
mais surtout ne jamais oublier que c'est
que c'est toute la misère la misère qui
s'exprime dans ces personnes là qui sont
aux anges et qui cumule général
généralement étoilé forcément du
ministre de l'intérieur oui ou non j'ai
pense qu'il est remis en cause est-ce
qu'il a bafoué les valeurs de gauche
comment les cépages et j'ai pas envie
d'en parler dans la mesure où tout le
monde sait ce qu'on pense parce qu'il ya
eu une affaire des roms avant parce que
on voit bien que
on est en train de déraper parce que
peut-être qu'on oublie encore une fois
qu'on est face à des frais mais moi je
ne je ne veux pas je on est en train de
crever de la politique politicienne on
est en train de crever dr des affaires
des uns et des autres moi je pense que
manuel valls devrait se poser de vraies
questions sur la manière dont il traite
ses dossiers après je ne veux pas hurler
avec les loups parce que je veux qu'on
reste sur les fonds d affaires est ce
que vous pensez pas justement donc que
c'est à l'elysée ou matignon en tout cas
de reprendre en main le dossier pour
rédigés éventuellement une nouvelle
circulaire clair et net et bien
franchement donné
que comme en tire des leçons qu'on en
tire des leçons pour que ce ne soit plus
possible pour que des enfants qui sont
scolarisés puisse continuer à être
scolarisés oui il faut le faire il faut
le faire après le président le premier
ministre
moi je ne donne d'injonctions à personne
je dis simplement que là on est face à
un vrai problème est qu'il faut trouver
des solutions et qui évidemment en
attendant d'avoir trouvé des solutions
cette famille a été traité de manière
scandaleuse donc leonarda puisse revenir
et qu'elle puisse en attendant que cette
affaire soit géré qu'elle puisse
reprendre ses études parce que pendant
ce temps là est en train de perdre des
heures de cours elle est en train de
glisser qu'il bloque les écoles lorsque
bon ou pas écoutez c'est le côté positif
de cette affaire c'est que on est en
train de tellement de parler de la
montée du front national la montée des
égoïsmes de la montre et de la montée du
de l'individualisme et puis du rejet de
l'autre les lycéens donne une belle
leçon je le dis il le faisait à amiens
bien avant d'affaires leonarda ils le
font là il nous donne une belle leçon de
citoyenneté d'humanisme et moi ça m'a ça
m'a fait chaud au coeur de voir qu'ils
pouvaient descendre dans la rue par
solidarité je trouve que c'est une belle
image est évidemment que je soutiens le
mouvement alors on va passer au jeudi si
vous le voulez bien l'ump fait sur
d'inventaire en tout cas ou presque
la réunion au siège parisien de l'ump
est bien eu lieu mais pas l'inventaire
du quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
puisque la quasi-totalité des têtes
d'affiché du parti manquait à l'appel le
président de l'ump lui étaient bien
présents il a dit veiller au
rassemblement écouter il ne s'agit pas
non plus de régler je ne sais quel
compte personnel ni avec nicolas sarkozy
ni avec françois fillon d'abord parce
que l'auto flagellation
ça ne fait jamais avancer les choses et
ensuite parce que moi je n'accepte pas
que certains fassent de la question du
bilan une occasion de je ne sais quel
règlement de comptes je demande
simplement qu'ils ne viennent pas alors
dire après au fil d'interviews ou de
discours ce qu'ils n'ont pas voulu dire
aujourd'hui les yeux dans les yeux aux
militants et sympathisants de notre
famille politique
alors le bilan du mps j'imagine que
c'est pas vraiment votre tasse de thé
c'est pas forcément votre parti mais moi
j'ai une question très de sa tresse
ainsi s'ils sont d'accord belle a écoulé
j'avais bien envie d'entendre votre avis
après je vous poserai autre question non
parce que on en revient au problème
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure c'est que on
est face à une montée des extrêmes
pourquoi parce qu'on n'est pas capable
proposer des alternatives aux gens et le
rôle de l'opposition démocratique c'est
de proposer des alternatives
et quand on a des problèmes au niveau du
gouvernement certainement mais quand on
a une opposition qui est incapable
justement de faire ce travail de bilan
et de perspectives politiques
eh bien on est face à un vrai problème
démocratique donc moi je suis concerné
par ce qui se passe à l'ump en tant que
démocrate parce que j'ai besoin moi de
voir une opposition qui n'est pas dans
la facilité mais qui est dans la
réflexion de fond est simple est-ce que
vous quand vous étiez dans l'opposition
vous avez accepté aussi de faire ce
travail d'inventaire d'essayer de de
définir ce que peut être ce que peut
être l'avenir votre position de 7 heures
à l'écouter en ce que personne n'est
parfait mais en tout cas on a essayé de
faire le travail on est on a essayé de
faire de travail et on a essayé
justement de proposer une réelle
alternative est ce qu'on nous on
continue de faire en tant que partenaire
de la majorité de continuer de dire au
ps attention là vous partez par l'âge on
pense qu'il vaudrait mieux s'orienter un
petit tapis majorité mais oui mais on
est là pour ça on est là pour dire à
constituer aussi comme comme rôle ça non
pas si simple parce que d'un côté on
nous traite de collabo parce qu on est
avec le parti socialiste qui ne fait pas
assez ce qui devrait faire selon selon
on nous dit et puis de l'autre côté
voilà donc non non on est on est dans
une position qui n'est pas si
confortable que ça mais on pense qu'on
doit apporter notre pierre et on pense
qu on a des propositions à faire là on
le voit sur la conversion écologique de
l'économie qui va créer des centaines de
milliers d'emplois on est dans une
période de crise on grâce à cette
conversion va créer des centaines de
milliers d'emplois je pense que se
mobiliser et se battre pour ça c'est
tout à notre honneur vraiment tout autre
sujet soulevé bien là aussi on va aller
sur un rapport qui a été établi au sénat
sur la prostitution il aide les
personnes concernées à s'en sortir le
détail avec nathalie dit ouah voilà des
exemples de petites cartes que nous
donnons aux personnes que nous
rencontrons sur les lieux de
prostitution
une adresse un numéro de téléphone en
cas de détresse mais aussi des
plaquettes d'information à l'amicale du
nid on va sur le terrain pour aider les
personnes prostituées à s'en sortir et
leur proposer un accompagnement
personnalisé
protections sociales minima sociaux
réinsertion professionnelle ces
démarches peuvent être difficile arrêt
et quand on a un passé de prostituées
l'ouverture des droits et complexe quand
il s'agit en particulier de la formation
et à l'emploi l'accompagnement vers la
formation à l'emploi
nécessite un travail avec les
institutions au syndicat des
travailleurs du sexe on considère au
contraire la prostitution comme un
métier normal mais on constate les
discriminations au quotidien accédez à
des droits bancaire le fait de pouvoir
même ouvrir un compte ou le droit
l'assurance droit l'emprunt il lit peut
y avoir des fortes discriminations le
fait d'être ailleurs c'est qu'il ya
plein de vin plein de d'administration
qui trouve cinq qui sont assez
sceptiques ou qui sont qui n'ont pas
forcément envie de deux drones les
services qui sont qui sont disponibles
pour les sénateurs les prostituées sont
d'abord des victimes dans leur rapport
jean pierre godefroy et chantal jouanno
veulent changer de regard sur la
prostitution il faut faire jouer une
présomption de victime pourtant voit une
personne prostituée et donc il faut
l'aider à sortir de la prostitution il
faut l'aider à dénoncer son réseau donc
il ya beaucoup de dispositions qu'on
préconise comme l'octroi d'un titre de
séjour comme une allocation temporaire
et l'accès au logement d'urgence un vrai
système de protection de la part de
l'état selon les sénateurs et dia va
1000 à 48 mille personnes prostituées en
france dont la grande majorité est
esclave de réseaux de traite
dans ce rapport il ya beaucoup de
mesures pour accompagner les personnes
qui se prostituent mais pas de mesures
de contrainte l'arsenal législatif est
absent vous le regrettez ça oui alors
c'est une situation très délicate à la
question des prostituées parce qu'il ya
d'un côté la question de l'esclavagisme
de la traite d'êtres humains qui est un
sujet très grave après il ya la question
de la prostitution en soi et là on voit
bien que les opinions divergent entre
ceux qui considèrent que c'est un
travail d'autres qui considère que de
toute façon vendre son corps c'est ce
n'est pas possible elle est donc voici
ce que moi la position que nous on a et
qui quelque part
recouvre les deux c'est que d'abord un
il faut absolument abolir le délit de
racolage passif qui les met dans des
situations très délicates parce que
elles deviennent pas du tout des
victimes mais là elles sont punies elle
même et puis là il ya un rapport de
d'olivier à l'assemblée nationale qui va
qui donne lieu à une proposition de loi
qui viserait à pénaliser le client donc
en fait à renverser des choses non je
pense que c'est très dangereux parce que
ça risque de précariser encore plus les
femmes ou les hommes d'ailleurs
prostituées puisqu'il serait encore plus
poussée vers se cacher et à la merci
justement de ses clients qui auraient
peur de se changer la loi et prônent les
deux rapports tout mélanger et refaire
une nouvelle loi offre tout mélanger je
ne sais pas mais en tout cas la question
des personnes prostituées doit sortir
absolument des grandes théories et se
confronter à la réalité de cette
situation et aider celles qui veulent
s'en sortir celles qui ont envie de
faire autre chose il faut les sortir du
système où elles sont où elle n'existe
pas donc il faut qu'elles existent il
faut qu'elle soit reconnue qu'elle soit
aidée après je pense que si on
s'activait vraiment sur ce qui existe
déjà dans la loi c'est à dire la
recherche la lutte contre les réseaux
mafieux qui
gère les prostituées je pense qu on
avancerait plus parce que la question
des réseaux pour moi est un est un
problème central bar appropriée on va
terminer cette émission avec des images
de notre dame des landes souvenez-vous
le mouvement a démarré il ya un an c'est
le plus de l'hebdo
vous proposait de suivre un des extraits
d'un documentaire qui s'appelle le
tarmac est dans le pré où l'histoire
d'un homme de mobilisation et
d'affrontements entre les forces de
l'ordre et les opposants à l'aéroport de
notre dame des landes pour toutes avant
première avec simon barbarie
à une vingtaine de kilomètres de nantes
des gendarmes suréquipés face à des
paysans en colère et des
alter-mondialistes provocateur
voilà près de 40 ans que le projet du
futur aéroport du grand ouest sur le
site de notre dame des landes divise
tournée l'année dernière le documentaire
le tarmac est dans le pré de thibaut
fériés donne la parole aux protagonistes
de deux visions un projet inutile
ruineux et anti-écologique pour les
porte-drapeaux de ce que l'on nomme la
guérilla bocagères on n'a pas besoin
d'aller loin pour puiser de l'eau ici et
les zones humides et bien on veut
contourner la loi pour faire un aéroport
sur une zone humide magnifique comme ça
un bocage magnifique comme ça c'est
impensable la loi dit aucune
construction sur les zones humides sauf
si on n'a pas de preuve qu'on ne peut
pas faire autrement alors là pour faire
autrement on à nantes atlantique qui
existe et qui est pas saturer une étape
essentielle au développement économique
de la région pour un front uni d'élus
locaux il faut aujourd'hui prendre en
compte la nécessité d'avoir du
développement pourquoi développement
parce que le développement c'est des
projets c'est cette l'emploi c'est de la
croissance ces mots là sont deux sont
pas des abstractions on ne provoque pas
d'emploi s'il n'y a pas de projet s'il
n'y a pas d'activité alors que le futur
aéroport du grand ouest devrait voir le
jour en 2017 ce documentaire capte des
enjeux et les rouages de la bataille de
notre dame des landes soit une
opposition radicale entre deux modèles
de développement et de croissance
pour 1
expulsion
un documentaire sur le 4 novembre
prochain une impression d'avoir deux
philosophies on entend dans ce
documentaire évidemment le concret
l'économique contre l'utopie le
développement durable
c'est conciliables tout ça utopie vous
parler de ceux qui n'ont pas changé
d'avis depuis 40 ans c'est bien cela
dont vous parlez le projet d'aéroport
justement l'aéroport a été décidée il ya
40 ans il ya quarante ans la situation
économique sociale écologique n'avait
rien à voir avec maintenant ces gens
n'ont pas évolué depuis 40 ans il faut
que maintenant il avance et qu'il
revienne aux réalités économiques et
écologiques et les réalités économiques
et écologiques c'est que maintenant on a
moins besoin d'aéroport on s'est rendu
compte que les transports à tout va par
avion n'était pas forcément les
meilleurs il faut relocaliser l'économie
et puis essayer de - développer des
infrastructures comme celle là qui sont
bouffeuse d'énergie mais plutôt
développer les infrastructures de
proximité
encore une fois qui est dans l'utopie et
qui est dans le réalisme je pense que
ceux qui sont restés sur des idées dia
40 ans le concorde un tout ça devrait se
remettre au goût du jour pour vous ces
deux réalités un considérable réalité
économique et écologique qui va gagner
le bras de fer l'écho d'un an non non le
colon alors ça je sais c'est la grande
mode d'opposer l'économie et l'écologie
mais pour réconcilier les deux mais
c'est ce que je vous ai dit la
transition écologique de l'économie les
économies d'énergie les énergies
renouvelables tous tous ces marchés là
c'est des centaines de millions
d'emplois des centaines de milliers par
don de 1000 emplois peut-être pas encore
restons modestes qui quels secteurs
économiques actuellement à un tel
potentiel de développement donc
l'économie et l'écologie sont liés à
ceux qui ont toujours tort que vous les
soutenez toujours bien sûr qu'on ait
soutient toujours on considère tout en
posant des questions
depuis le début depuis le début nous
avons fait un accord de gouvernement en
enlevant notre dame des landes de
l'accord on a depuis le début et a bien
constat de désaccord sur cette position
ça n'a pas évolué depuis on considère
qu'au contraire les études qui sont
menées actuellement qui ont été
commandées par le gouvernement vont
plutôt dans notre sens donc on voit bien
cet aéroport est inutile coûteux
dangereux pour environnement donc
j'aurai documentaire message conclut
garçons d'avoir été notre arrivée on se
retrouvait son prochaine ktm bonne
semaine à tous